your sunglasses the laser beam
containing glasses they have some sort
of chain on the back so if they did fall
off you could find them quickly maybe a
sports like a green bay packers is that
who you like you cheese head
what the [ __ ]
you like dogs i do like think about a
dog
that died because your glasses fell off
sorry mark what are you gonna do you're
gonna let wolverine lead the x-men he's
good at sleeping with your girlfriend
come again
if wolverine touches a vagina does that
heal
what does it see
it's gross
you never just want to whip them off and
see what your eyes look like your baby
blues
i've actually never seen my own eyes how
sad i've never run walked
leaned
sat in in style except that one time
that
you know i had gene put me
do you shower with those on
of course i do of course otherwise
otherwise you would
kill is that what you're gonna say kill
everyone
everyone in the shower
everyone on the other side of the shower
which i checked the blueprints that's
beast's room
actually the shower that you use on the
other side is beasts
the shower you use uh i looked in
the other side is beast's laboratory
laboratory
beast laboratory it's not a big
everything just get do it do until it
stops me from i don't just go actually
the shower that you use on the other
side is beast's laboratory
it's a good thing these are on because
i'm actually crying
so no more beast because somebody wanted
to wash his face with saint ive's
exfoliating scrub hmm
that's why he died because you had
blackheads
on my eyes